The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome back.
Sorry for the
technical blip there.
OK, so I guess lecture two.
I challenged you.
We talked about the phase
space of the simple pendulum,
and I challenged you to come
up with a simple algorithm.
I guess I didn't
say simple, but I
challenged you to come
up with an algorithm
to try to, in some
sort of minimal way,
change the phase
plot of this system
so that the fixed points
that used to be unstable
become stable and vise versa.
So today we're going to do that.
I don't know if anybody
do that for fun?
Yeah, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so today we're
going to do that.
So yeah, the question is, can
we use optimal control now,
numerical optimal control, to
reshape these dynamics, OK.
And I want to
start by doing sort
of an evil thing
but something that's
going to make thinking
about it a lot easier.
We're going to discretize
everything, OK.
So let's start by--
we're going to discretize
state, actions, and time, OK.
So I'm actually going to
take my vector of x, which
lived on the real numbers,
and start thinking
about integer number of states.
I'll say what I mean by that.
OK.
And I'm going to take my
actions, my continuous action
space, which I've
been thinking of as u,
and I'm going to turn
that into a discrete state
space, a discrete action space.
And I'm going to
take time and turn it
into some integer,
discrete time, OK.
So and I'm going to try to
be-- throughout the lectures,
throughout the notes, I tried
to be very, very careful
to use X and U and time
for continuous things
and S for states, A for
actions, N for discrete things.
So we might find
ourselves in situations
where we have continuous
state and discrete actions
or some other combination,
but that should be a code.
OK, so if we want to-- if we're
willing to discretize state
and time, then maybe one
way to think about that
on this picture is by thinking
of every one of these--
this was my quick
cartoon of the phase
plot of the simple pendulum.
Let's think about
identifying each one
of these possible states
in the phase portrait
as a particular state, OK.
These little nodes, possible
states we can live in.
And through actions, we can
transition to different states,
if you see what I'm
doing without drawing
100,000 circles here.
So let's tile the state
space with discrete states.
You could also think
of it as drawing a grid
and calling each box
in the grid a state.
And what that allows
us to do-- we're also
discretizing actions, so
we have a finite number
of possible options
coming out of each state.
It allows us to turn the
continuous time optimal control
problem into a simple
graph search problem, OK.
Graph search, we
know how to do well.
We're really good at
that in computer science.
OK, so let's see how
far we can get first
by just thinking about this very
non-linear, very dynamic thing
on a graph search, OK.
So we're going to do
numerical optimal control.
This is-- in
particular, when people
talk about the dynamic
programming algorithm,
they're often talking about
discretizing state and actions.
And we're going to use the
standard optimal control
formulation.
I'm going to start
with a finite horizon
and say that my cost of
being in state x, time t
is h of x at the final time.
All right, this is the
continuous time optimal
control.
And I'm going to start thinking
of that now as being in state S
at integer time N
and having me be
at some final cost
on S plus a sum
from N equals 0
to N of g SA, OK.
And my dynamics now are
going to be of the form S--
maybe I should even write
more explicitly, S N plus 1
is a function of SN, AN, OK.
OK, so again,
dynamic programming
exploits the fact that you can
write this in a recursive form.
So if I want to find
the optimal cost
to go, which I'll call J
star, at the final time,
it's just h of S, right.
And going backwards
in time, this
is just going to be the min over
a of g S, a plus h of S prime,
where S prime is.
Right?
I'll get one-- if N is--
N minus 1, I get one
of these, and then I
get the final cost, OK.
And going backwards, we
have this recursive form,
which is min over a g S, a plus
the cost to go from S prime
and n plus 1 using
that same S prime.
OK, I want to make sure
you see why that is, why
this-- this is magical, right?
The fact that I can
summarize my optimal
cost to go by doing a min
over a single action, that's
really magical.
Just to make that extremely
clear, think about J star
at N minus 2, let's say.
So I have to minimize
over two actions.
I have to minimize over, let's
say I'll call them a1 and a2.
I have two steps left to go.
So I have to minimize S
at a1 plus g of S prime,
let's call it, a2 plus
h of S double prime.
That's my minimization
that I'm trying
to solve in order to find
the optimal cost to go,
where S prime is f of S, a.
S double prime is f of S prime.
This is a1, and this is a2.
I'm just expanding this
sum for the last two g's.
And the cool thing is that,
because of this additive form
of g, this term doesn't depend
at all on my decision a2.
I'm given a current state S, and
I have to decide my action a1.
Nothing about this term
depends at all on a2, OK.
In contrast, this one
does depend on a1,
because S prime depends on a1.
This one depends on a1 and a2.
This one certainly
depends on a2.
You see what I'm saying?
So I can rewrite this
as min over a1 f of S a1
plus min over a2 g of S prime
a2 plus h of S double prime.
I could just move
that min inside
to the only terms that matter.
This is intended to be
a moment of clarity,
and I don't see a
clarity on your faces.
Does that make sense, that
this doesn't depend on a2?
I know I'm going to- a1 is
my action at time N minus 2.
a2 is my action at N minus 1.
The action I take next time
has absolutely no effect
on my current state
or my current action.
So the great thing is
this here is just--
this whole term
right here is just
J star of S prime at, I'm
calling it, N minus 1 here.
So it's really the
fact that we're
taking this min over
this additive form that
allows us to write the recursive
statement like this that says,
the best thing I can
do with additive cost
and all these things is
to, in a single step,
take the action which minimizes
my one step cost combined
with the cost I'm going to
get from being in the state I
transition to for
the rest of time.
It's a magical thing.
At whatever time I'm at, I only
have to think one action ahead
if I've already got my
J star computed, OK.
Simultaneously, it's
saying that I can
compute the optimal cost to go.
I could compute the optimal--
I know exactly how
much cost I'm going
to incur from any state, given
I follow the optimal policy,
if I just work
backwards in time.
And when I'm in
time N minus 1, I
don't have to think
about the actions I
was going to take beforehand.
As long as I know
what state I'm in,
because that state
encompasses every action I've
taken in the past, that state
contains all the information,
all I have to think
about is the last action
I'm going to take to decide
my optimal policy one
step from the end of time, OK.
So the fact that you
can solve these things
backwards in time, that's the
principle of optimality, OK.
Ask questions if you
don't like what I said.
I think that the graphics
that are about to come
are going to make
things clear, too.
OK, so what does that mean?
What are the
implications of that?
All right, for the
additive costs,
I can compute J star recursively
from the end of time, which,
in this case, is N back to 0.
And the optimal action,
the optimal policy,
which I then want to
call pi star, which
could in general depend on the
time, is just argmin over a.
It's the action which
minimizes that same expression.
So I can compute J star
recursively backwards in time,
and if I know J star,
then I essentially know
my optimal policy.
I know the best action, OK.
So but for this reason, the
fact that the cost to go,
the cost I expect to
incur given I'm in state S
and I'm running from
time N, the cost to go
becomes a very central
construct in optimal control.
All right, so part
of the goal for today
is to give you some more
intuition about J star,
OK, because it's actually
a very intuitive thing,
but you can be lost, I
think, in the equations.
So let's give you more
intuition about that.
I'm going to do that by
getting a little bit more
abstract, well, simultaneously
abstract and concrete.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because
it's finite horizon.
AUDIENCE: You know
that the reward
function is dependent on time.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
included that.
You can make the reward
function depend on time.
But even if the reward function,
or cost function in my world,
is--
there's a difference between
optimal control people
and reinforcement
learning people.
The optimal control
people are pessimists.
Everything's a cost.
And the reward reinforcement
learning people
give rewards out.
So I guess I'm a pessimist.
So yeah, so my cost is actually
not a function of time.
I could have made it that.
But because there's a
finite horizon time,
that means my policy and my
cost to go function still
depends on time.
Because if time
ends in one step,
I'm going to do something
different than if time ends
arbitrarily far in the future.
OK.
So we're going to--
my goal here is to get
intuition about cost to go
and dynamic programming, which
I'm often going to call DP, OK.
And I'm going to do it with
the grid world example.
This is right out of the
reinforcement learning books.
OK, so in that
pendulum phase plot,
I discretized the
state space, and I
started talking about
transitions between states, OK.
I can make that even more
transparent by saying,
OK, now you're a
trashcan robot in a room.
You're going to be in
one of these tiles.
You're on one of these
blocks, so there's
a finite, discrete
state space, OK.
I won't draw a trashcan
robot, but let's say I'm here.
And when you're here, you
have five discrete actions
you can take.
You can move up, you can
move right, down, left,
or you can sit still.
OK.
And discrete states
and discrete time.
Every time you take an
action, in the next time step,
you'll be in the next grid box.
OK.
Let's say I've got a goal
state somewhere in the world.
Well, we can formulate plenty
of good optimal control problems
to get us to that goal state.
So plenty of good
cost to go functions
in the additive form--
let's say I want to do minimum--
I want to get there
in the minimum time.
Well, then I can just
set g of S, a to be--
to actually have it
in units of time,
I should put a 1 if S
is not at the goal and 0
if S is in the goal, OK.
And I don't actually
care about actions.
I have five discrete
actions I can pick
from whenever I'm in a state.
If I'm not at the goal, I'm
going to incur a cost of 1.
So it's in my best interest
as a trashcan robot
to get to the goal.
If I'm minimizing
that cost, I'm going
to get the goal as
fast as possible.
And actually, the
units, the cost to go
will tell me the number
of steps to get there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I'm going to do
that graphically.
But let's say there's
a finite horizon now,
but this is how I'm going to
get to infinite horizon, so.
And let's say that
h of S is just 0.
I don't really care where
I am at the end of time.
Or I could have h of S
be this same function.
That would be fine, too.
OK.
How's is it going to look?
What is J-- well, let's
be specific about h.
Let's make h actually
be the same as g here.
So I'll say it's g
S with the 0 action.
So since this doesn't depend
on actions, it doesn't matter.
Let's say h is the same
function as g there.
So what does my cost to
go look like at time N?
My optimal cost to go
given I'm in some state,
and it's time N. This
is a function over S,
and I'm time N. And
what is that function?
AUDIENCE: g.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, if I'm not in
the goal, it's that.
It's the same as g,
or h in this case.
OK.
What does g star of S
N minus 1 look like?
Now I have time to
take one action, OK.
So--
AUDIENCE: One step away
from the goal is 1.
If you're on the goal, it's
0, but anywhere else, it
would just be 1.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
Right?
If I'm on the goal, I can do
nothing, incur zero cost to go.
So the best thing for me
to do if I'm on the goal
is to stay there, OK.
If I'm a long way from
the goal, then I'm
not going to get to
the goal in two steps,
so I'm going to incur
two units of cost.
I'll say loosely far from goal.
And then there's this
in-between place,
which is if I'm one
step away from the goal,
I can take the right action
and get there and incur
only one unit of cost.
All right, what's
it going to be--
what's J S N minus
2 going to be?
It's going to be 3,
2, or 1, depending
on how closely-- if
I'm near the goal,
I've got a chance of
getting to the goal
and stopping this
insane adding cost.
Stop the madness.
Get to the goal.
Otherwise, I'm going to just
incur the cost no matter
what I do, OK.
So what's the optimal policy?
If I'm on the goal, what's the
best-- the best action to take
is to sit still.
If I'm one step away from the
goal, the best thing to do
is to move to the goal, whether
it's up, down, left, or right.
What if I'm out here?
What's the best
thing for me to do?
Doesn't matter at all.
I can do anything I want.
I'm still going
to incur the cost,
so you might as well just choose
your policy at random, OK.
So optimal policies
aren't necessarily unique.
Sometimes multiple actions
are equally optimal.
OK, here's your world.
I have put the goal always
at 2,3, just randomly, OK.
You are a blue star.
The goal is a red asterisk.
It's a-- take you back to the
'80s or something, video games.
OK.
So let's just very simply--
I'm going to run this value
iteration algorithm on it, OK,
and I'm going to plot, at every
step of the algorithm, the cost
to go, OK, and the
policy, actually.
So it's not going to be--
I have my more general
value iteration
code that's not going to be
quite as beautiful, but--
[TYPING]
OK.
Well, that went pretty fast.
There was supposed
to be pause there.
Let me get that--
add a pause in
there quick, but--
OK.
Here is J at time--
at J at capital N.
My cost function
is 0 if I'm at the goal,
1 everywhere else, OK.
My policy, it doesn't
matter what I choose.
I've actually chosen to do--
I didn't put this--
I didn't give you a key, but 0
is the do nothing action, OK.
So this just has do
nothing everywhere.
This is the lazy
policy, I guess.
And the cost it's
going to get is
it's going to get no cost if
it's at the goal, one cost
if it's everywhere else.
OK, if I'm now
computing J S N minus 1,
you guys told me what that is.
That says it's 0
here, it's 1 here,
it's 2 everywhere else, right.
And the co-- now you
can see my key here.
Orange must mean move down,
red must mean move to the left,
green must mean move to
the right, and so on, OK.
The value-- this
backwards propagation,
this dynamic
programming propagation
is a very beautiful and
intuitive thing, OK.
Every time I take a step, a few
more states become reachable.
In that amount of time,
I can get to the goal.
The resulting cost to
go function is simple.
It's just the distance, the
number of cells from the goal,
yeah.
And the policy, again,
it's not unique.
But this one, just
because of the ordering
I chose, and I just do
a min over the actions,
says it's always going to
move down in that orange area,
it's always going to
move up in the blue area,
and it's just going to--
so that's one of the
optimal policies, all right.
Now Alborz asked
a good question,
what's my horizon time?
So I'm actually just working
backwards from some arbitrary
capital N and just
going backwards in time
further and further.
But it turns out for this
problem, and for many problems,
everything converges, OK.
After some amount of time,
the optimal cost to go
stops changing, and I know
that's my optimal policy.
Walk down.
And this is too simple.
This is painfully simple.
But I think that
intuition is going
to take us a long way with
the value methods, OK.
AUDIENCE: So, Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In this example, the
optimal policy is not unique.
PROFESSOR: The optimal
policy is not unique.
The guy could have just as well
gone left first and then down.
So how does that manifest
itself in those equations?
There's multiple min over a's.
There's multiple a's that give
me the same J star S and N
minus-- or plus 1, whatever.
Multiple actions give me
the same long-term cost,
so I could equally
pick any of them, yeah?
OK, to make a more
careful analogy
to the more
continuous world, that
was a perfectly good
minimum time problem.
I could have equally well chosen
a different cost function.
Oh wait, let's put the
obstacles back in, all right.
So the cool thing
is obstacles aren't
going to make it any
harder for us to solve
this problem in our head.
It's a nice observation
that they don't actually
make it any harder for the
algorithm to solve it either.
And that's a general principle.
That's something I definitely
want you to get out
of this course,
is that when we're
doing analytical optimal
control, every piece
you add to the dynamics makes
things cripplingly difficult.
And so you have to stay with
these very simple dynamical
systems.
OK, the computational
algorithms are actually
pretty insensitive to how
complex the dynamics are.
They're going to break down
in a different way, OK.
So there's these different
tools for different-- that are
good for different problems.
And there's a lot of problems
which are very amenable
to these computational
tools that people aren't--
I mean, you can solve brand
new problems pretty easily
with some of these algorithms.
OK, so let's think of
another cost function.
Let's do the equivalent
of a quadratic regulator.
I just had that whole
spiel and forgot
to run the boundary-- the
obstacles together in Soapbox.
OK, so now I'm just going
to put in some obstacle.
And if you see-- whoops, sorry.
If my state--
OK, so I promised to use S and
a in my notes and on the board,
but I guess I didn't
do it in my code.
Sorry.
So x equals the goal,
then the cost to go is--
the cost, instantaneous
cost, is 0.
Otherwise it's 1.
If there's an obstacle, I just
give it a high cost of 10.
So if I put that obstacle
function in there,
then I've got my same
0 cost for the goal.
I've got a 1 cost
almost everywhere,
but I've got a 10 there.
That's my cost function.
And as I backup, a couple
of things happened.
First, this thing
quickly figures out
how to get off that
obstacle as fast as possible
and decides not to
go there anymore.
And then as you back
up the cost function,
the colors are a
little more muted
because I have this
high color here.
But the same basic
algorithm plays out
until it covers the space.
And my s-- oh, that was a--
[LAUGHTER]
--lucky initial condition.
OK, good.
Now he has to go around.
Wow.
OK, so adding an obstacle in the
grid world is clearly trivial.
It's nice to think that adding
an obstacle when I get back
to the pendulum
would be trivial,
because that's not trivial
for most of your other control
derivations.
OK, so minimum-- the
quadratic regulator now.
Now here, the cost
I want is x of u,
in the continuous world is some
x minus x goal transpose Q x
minus x goal.
And you have to map that
down into the integer
world, the states.
There's not a particularly
clean way to write that,
so I'm just going to
allow you to imagine
that it's trivial to code.
Imagine that transition.
OK, now my cost function
is just penalizing me
for being away from the goal.
But it's not a 0 and 1.
It's penalizing me more smoothly
for being away from the goal.
So what's the best thing to do?
The best thing to do is
still to get to the goal
as quickly as possible.
It actually doesn't really
change the optimal policy here,
but it's a more
smooth cost function,
which, in some problems,
gives you nice properties.
It turns out the optimal policy
is more unique in this case.
But that would have been an
optimal for the minimum time
problem, too.
And it converges nicely and goes
to the goal in the same way,
and works fine with the
obstacle, of course.
OK?
Good.
So now you have a little
bit more intuition
to work with on these
cost to go functions.
A couple of important
things happened there
that I want to highlight.
First of all, I really want
you to think in terms of cost
to go functions.
They're really intuitive.
The cost that I will obtain
till the end of time,
the optimal cost to go says
if I'm acting optimally,
this is the cost
I'm going to incur.
And the optimal cost to go
gives me the optimal policy, OK.
And just to calibrate
you here, J star
is called the
optimal cost to go,
but it's also sometimes called
a value function, optimal value
function.
A bunch of different communities
talk about the same things
with different words.
These are the optimists.
These are the pessimists.
OK, the other thing that we
saw is that for many problems,
the limit as N goes
to negative infinity--
I know that's a silly thing
to say, I guess, but--
that a lot of times
this thing actually
goes to some well posed J star.
It doesn't have to.
Sometimes it blows up.
Another way to think of
this is that I said J S of N
is S of capital N. It's the
limit of this as capital
N goes to infinity, if you
think of it in the forward way.
So in order for this thing to
converge to some nice solution,
this sum had better
converge in the limit.
For my choice of g for
the minimum time problem,
and for the quadratic
regulator, both of these
had the property that
when you get to the goal,
you stop incurring cost.
So that integral-- as long
as you can get to the goal,
that integral-- the sum,
sorry, is going to converge.
If I had chosen that
I give a cost of 1
when I'm at the goal and
2 when I'm anywhere else,
then it wouldn't have converged.
The cost to go would have
gone to that same shape,
but then that shape
would have just
kept increasing every time
I go farther back in time.
That whole function
would just move up by one
every increment of time, OK.
But for a lot of
problems, we do have
this nice limiting behavior,
OK, and that gives rise
to the infinite
horizon problems.
So so far, I had talked
about finite horizon,
but a lot of time,
a lot of problems
we write as infinite horizon.
OK.
When your problems are
infinite horizon, J and J star
don't depend on time anymore.
And the optimal policy
doesn't depend on time.
So J star and pi, all these
things are just functions of S,
not of time, OK.
And for these to be well posed,
that sum had better converge.
Now just to say it, but not to
dwell on it, a lot of people
do write other formulations
that handle that.
For instance, a lot of
people do discounting.
A lot of people like to solve
problems of this form, OK, just
to make it more likely that
that sum's going to converge,
for instance.
And there's some problems which
really do have discounting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's
less than 1 [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you.
Good.
Good call.
Thank you.
OK, so you know the
basic dynamic programming
equations, no?
Let me just say one word
about implementation,
if you want to go home and
make your own '80s graphics
game in Matlab.
For discrete states,
discrete actions, J,
even J star of S at
some N, it's a vector.
Typically I think of it as
sort of a dimension of S
by one vector.
And dimension isn't
the right word.
This is-- so the
cardinality of S,
let's say, something
like that, a big S,
the number of possible
states by one vector.
And it's very practical to write
that recursion for all states
as a vector equation.
So if I think of J
star as being a vector,
I have to do a min
over a of g S, a.
But g is another vector
which depends on a.
It's an S by 1 plus--
I can write it as
a vector equation
where this is a vector.
This is a matrix.
This is the transition matrix.
And this is my vector again.
And then transition
matrix is just 1 if f iA
equals J and 0 otherwise.
OK.
That's just a standard
graph notation.
So it's trivial to code
these things in Matlab
with just a bunch of
matrix manipulations.
OK, we understand everything
about the grid world.
I think it is a very
helpful example, actually.
Now let's think about the
more continuous problems
that I care about.
What if, instead of having
the dynamics of this
moving left, right, whatever,
my dynamics, my transitions came
from my equations of motion
from one of the systems
we care about?
So let's think about
the double integrator.
q double dot equals u.
Let's do the min time problem.
I can use the same minimum time
cost function I did before, OK.
[TYPING]
OK.
This one, I didn't leave
the pause in there,
but look what happens.
Oops, sorry.
Meant to do that.
Make it bigger.
I pop the same--
let me turn the lights down.
I pop that same exact
set of equations.
I run the same value iteration
algorithm, dynamic programming
algorithm.
I should have said,
people tend to call it
value iteration for when you
take the infinite horizon
version and dynamic
programming if you call it--
if you do the finite
horizon, but they're
exactly the same thing, OK.
So I might accidentally
say value iteration
because I'm used to it.
OK, so I took my double
integrator dynamics.
I discretized my space.
I made my cost function
exactly the same
as the minimum
time cost function
I used in the grid
world, where there's
a 0 cost of being at the
goal and 1 everywhere else.
And look what pops out.
This is the cost to go function,
is a function of state,
and that's the policy.
Remind you of anything?
Right?
Now I've got a big
disclaimer that
goes at the end of the lecture,
but for now, let's just
say that that's the
perfect solution.
The discretization is going to
make this thing a little bit
wrong.
I'm going to say a
few things about that
at the end of the class.
But the cool thing is that
I pop my cost function in.
I pop my continuous
dynamical system.
It's discretized.
[CLICK] Run dynamic programming.
As I back it up, it
converges to some--
as N goes back, it
does converge for this.
It was the minimum time problem.
And I get my optimal
policy out, which
is a bang bang policy,
which is decelerate
when you're at the
bottom, accelerate
when you're at that top.
And that switching
surface shows up in green
just because it's interpolated.
But when you know it, that's
what we know about bang bang
controllers, OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you have to
encode that your only three
actions were full forward,
full backward, and--
PROFESSOR: The minimum
over a is always
going to choose the rails.
In fact, in this
implementation, they
could have chosen in
between things, and that's
what it did right on the
switching surface because
of some--
it chose 0.
AUDIENCE: OK, so you left
the general just as--
PROFESSOR: I left it general.
Yeah.
So always, when I
discretize the state
and I discretize the actions
of these continuous problems,
I'm left with a
finite set of states,
a finite set of actions.
So it can't pick unbounded.
It's fundamentally bounded in
actions that it can choose,
and it chose those bounds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: How do you define
the transition model?
PROFESSOR: Good.
I'm going to say some words
about that in a minute,
too, OK.
Yeah.
But not yet.
Just give me a minute.
OK, let's say we
want to solve the LQR
problem, the quadratic
regulator cost for this.
[TYPING]
So I animated the brick for
you just to keep it exciting.
OK, so what pops out?
This beautiful quadratic
cost to go function, OK.
Now this is a little bit off.
It's supposed to be
a linear function.
It almost is, but there's
some saturation because
of my actuator limits, OK.
But within the resolution of
sort of my discrete actions,
that's what we expected, OK.
So I can do this for the brick.
I'm going to tell you the
caveats again in a minute,
and I'm going to tell you the
interpolation in a minute.
But first I just want to
help you realize that this--
we can pop these
equations in if we're
willing to discretize the
state and action space.
Even for pretty hard problems,
I can just [CLICK] let it go.
It's pretty fast, too, actually.
OK.
So now why not--
analytically, we had a hard
time doing the pendulum,
those nonlinear equations, OK.
But if we tile the space,
turn it into a graph,
then I can run the
exact same algorithm
on the simple pendulum, OK.
So let's do that.
[TYPING]
What am I going to get here?
So minimum time for
the simple pendulum.
I've got my pause back in here.
It's hard to see, but
there's actually--
it's 1 everywhere except for
0 at the goal, which is the--
now I'm in phase space,
so that's pi at 0.
That's my unsteady
fixed point, OK.
I've got a blue 0 there,
1 everywhere else.
At the end of time, my
action is just do nothing,
because there's no
benefit to doing anything.
And as I back up in time, this
will give you a key to what--
you can see a little bit about
my interpolation as I do this.
OK, then it starts giving
me incentive to move.
Again, when you can't
get to the goal,
that's actually
just noise there.
But this thing
quickly figures out--
oops.
Let me do the same thing and
let it not plot every time.
Figures out a cost
to go function,
the optimal cost to go
function, and an optimal policy.
Now it looks a
little noisy there.
Again, we're going to
talk about the sensitivity
to discretization.
But this is very
much a bang bang
policy, with the
blue area being,
do one action, the red area
doing the other action.
The switching surface is
actually pretty complicated.
It's some complicated
function of state,
but it gets this beautifully
smooth cost to go function, OK.
Now let's take a second and
look at the phase plots here.
Let me actually do
it in order here.
So this is the phase plot of
the damped passive pendulum,
OK, the original one we
thought about in class.
I just drew a few
lines to help you.
So if I start at
downright position
with a little bit of velocity,
I'd slow down and stop.
If I start near an
unstable fixed point
with near 0 velocity,
then I actually
fall down and go like this
and end up standing still
near the closest
unstable fixed point, OK.
Now if I do my feedback
linearization invert gravity
controller to stabilize
the fixed point, then
what's the phase plot
going to look like?
It's going to look
just like this,
but it's going to be
moved over there, right?
So let's make sure that's true.
Ah, what did I call it?
Invert gravity.
OK, yeah.
So I see the exact same things.
Used to be my stable fixed
point are now going over
to the closest unstable one.
This works great.
The only objection
to it is it required
an enormous amount of
torque to just pretend
like you're inverted gravity.
OK, so what's the minimum time
solution going to look like?
AUDIENCE: It's going
to depend on what
your torque constraint is.
PROFESSOR: It's going
to depend on my torque
constraint is, yeah.
So for whatever torque
constraint I have now,
you could even figure
out the units here.
My torque constraint was
chosen to be something
like half of the stall torque
required to hold out like this.
Then let's see what happens.
This is the minimum
time solution,
which is exactly right.
If I had more torque
to give, it could
have gotten out there quicker.
And this added enough that,
after going around once,
it could get up to the top, OK.
Let me see.
Why is it not drawing anymore?
I've got this [INAUDIBLE].
Oop.
So that was-- that's a
random initial condition.
So from the one I had
shown, it took one pump.
That one took two pumps,
and that gets it to the top.
OK, but now, remember,
my original challenge
was to not just get to
the top in minimum time.
This is minimum time
with bounded torque,
so that's a little
bit more satisfying.
I don't want to
pump in more torque
than I could possibly implement.
But what if I want to be
sensitive about the torque?
I want to get to
the top, but I don't
want to use a bunch of energy.
OK, now the quadratic cost
function makes a lot of sense,
OK.
So I'm going to put
a quadratic cost
on being away from the
top and a big quadratic
cost on using actions.
So that'll give me some sense of
minimally stabilizing the top,
OK.
What's that one
going to look like?
Would you expect
it to look like--
phase plot going.
AUDIENCE: Basically
in phase space,
it will more turns to get up
there on the top [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK.
What about if it's near the top?
Is there going to look like
a damp pendulum at the top?
What's it going to do?
AUDIENCE: Well, if it's headed
the wrong way near the top,
it will probably swing
all the way around.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Right.
AUDIENCE: But if you put
too much cost on distance,
it might end up quickest
on the [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Perfect, OK.
So let's switch this to be
my quadratic regulator cost.
Right, so that's what you said.
Took more pumps to get up.
And if you plot the
phase plot from a couple
of these different places--
oh.
Crap, sorry.
I thought I picked initial
conditions that were
far enough to show you that.
This is what you said, OK.
This one happens to be close
enough that it got to the top.
This one took a lot of
pumps and got out there.
But the point I was
trying to illustrate--
I guess I need to either
penalize torque a little bit
more or--
I never change things
by a factor of 2.
It's too slow.
Oh, I made it not move.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
But it showed my point, OK.
So yeah, it has no incentive
to move from the bottom.
It says, I'm going to incur
more cost by moving than
by getting close to the goal.
Not getting close.
OK, but up at the
top, it is able to--
given it was near the
top with some velocity,
with a little effort, it's worth
going around and stabilizing
itself at the top.
Yeah?
OK.
Good.
AUDIENCE: If you
iterate it far enough,
it should go at the top, but--
PROFESSOR: No.
Let's see.
So--
AUDIENCE: It's because
of the damping.
PROFESSOR: It's
because of the damping.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good.
Because that is actually
the steady state solution
I'm plotting.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm.
OK.
[RUSTLING]
So if you care about
simple pendula--
sorry-- and you want
optimal solutions,
this looks like a pretty
satisfying way to do it.
You could up with your
arbitrary cost functions
and see what you get.
It runs in no time
on my laptop, and you
get things that look like
optimal policies, nice phase
plots, you name it, OK.
What's the catch?
First catch is, how do
I do the interpolation?
How do I make that
transition matrix?
So on my pendulum example,
I discretized some states.
I have a handful--
I've already
discretized actions,
and I've got some
other states over here
that they've
already discretized.
I'd have to be pretty
remarkably lucky to have it
that the random
actions that I chose,
integrated for some
small amount of time,
actually landed right on top
of one of my other states.
In fact, they tend to land
in between the states,
OK, so we do a little bit of
interpolation between them.
And one of the reasons I showed
you that transition matrix
form is that it's actually
quite OK, quite standard,
to say that my transition
matrix, my T from S
to S prime as a
function of a is some--
let me just handwave it here--
but is some interpolated
set of weights for S1 close.
[LAUGHS] OK.
Zach just showed me a sign
that said, the pendulum works.
Having Matlab licensing issues.
So we might--
I was hoping to run these
on the real pendulum.
We'll do it on
Tuesday if not today.
[LAUGHS] I don't know whey
he didn't just say that,
but there's a big
bright green sign.
So let me write it like
this for the moment, OK.
So if I end up being near
some states in two dimensions,
I tend to interpolate between
the three closest states, OK.
So I'll call those Sy and S1--
Si, Sj, Sk, and I get some
interpolants, W1, W2, and W3.
They'd better sum to one, OK.
And there's actually
lots of ways to do that.
So actually, in previous
times I've given the class,
I went into some
detail about that.
I think that you could--
if you care about it, there's
a lot of ways to do that.
You could use the
Matlab interp2 function.
The one we use is called
barycentric interpolation.
In the RL community, that was
popularized by Munoz and Moore.
That'll be cited in the notes.
And it uses-- if
you're operating
in an N-dimensional space, it
uses N plus 1 interpolants.
So in a two-dimensional
space, it
uses the three closest points.
If you're in a
four-dimensional space,
it uses the five
closest points, OK.
And there's a very
clean, simple algorithm
to find the factors of
that interpolant, OK.
The caveat is that
everything spreads out.
If I simulate my dynamics,
my graph dynamics,
what it's roughly saying is that
if I started from this state,
I'm going to be a little bit
in that state, a little bit
in that--
a little bit in state 48,
a little bit in state 52.
And then my transition's
out of there,
so I get this diffusion across
my graph of where my state is,
if that makes sense.
Yeah?
And that's why you get some
of the smoothing effects
that you saw in the plots, OK.
There's a bigger
problem with that.
The smoothing effects a lot of
times don't look too dangerous,
but they can do bad
things to your solution
if you're not careful, OK.
So the big caveat
is the solution
you get is optimal only
for the discrete system.
We hope that it's approximately
optimal for continuous,
but compared to the
finite element analysis
world or the computational
fluid dynamics world,
or other people that solve
these kind of problems,
we have relatively less
strict understanding of when--
of how bad this approximation
can be compared--
based on the discretization.
There might actually be
people out there that know it.
I don't know how to
tell you how bad it's
going to get with the appro--
with the discretization.
But I will ask you
on your problem set
to plot the bang bang solution
of the double pendulum--
or, sorry, of the
double integrator,
and plot the analytical
solution on top of it.
And you'll see that
if you're not careful,
it's not just a
little bit wrong.
It can be systematically wrong.
The switching surface turns
out in the wrong place.
And we'll ask you to think a
little bit about why that is,
OK.
That's really the
only caveat if you
about low dimensional problems.
The more cited one,
though, of course,
is that there's this
curse of dimensionality.
The only reason that everybody
doesn't use this stuff
is because if I had a 10
degree of freedom robot
and I had to break up
that 10-dimensional space
in discrete points, discrete
buckets, and made a graph,
I would need a bigger computer.
Not just a little bit bigger, an
exponentially bigger computer,
OK.
So you have to be able
to discretize your space,
and discretizing the
space is exponentially
expensive in the
number of states, OK.
But so people
actually-- historically,
value methods were very
popular in the '80s, say.
And there's a lot
of work that we're
going to talk about that
continues to be popular,
about using approximations,
where you don't
do a strict
discretization, but you
do it so to try to
approximate these costs,
these dynamic programming
algorithms with function
approximation.
But because of this sort
of curse of dimensionality,
a lot of people switched
gears to a different class
of optimization algorithms
based more on the Pontryagin
principle and more
on gradient methods.
We're going to talk
about those, too.
But I think we have to
remember that since the 1980s,
our computers actually
got a lot better, OK.
Sounds silly, but
so in the '80s,
they could tile
two-dimensional spaces,
and three-dimensional hurt.
Now we could probably do four,
five, six-dimensional spaces,
OK.
We actually did for--
we made that airplane
land on a perch
by just tiling the state
space and doing brute force
computation on that, OK.
So you should look around.
If there's some hard
control problems that
are four-dimensional or
less that you consider
to be unsolved,
you could probably
just hand them the
dynamic programming
and get a very
nice solution, OK.
And say, hey, you couldn't
do it 10 years ago,
but I can do it
today on my laptop.
Awesome.
OK.
So unless Zach
appears here, there's
only one last thing
I want to say,
and that is I want
to observe quickly--
we talked about the fact
that optimal policies are not
unique.
But there's more things
you can learn by staring
at these guys a little bit.
Let's put my R down to
something more manageable.
Go, go, go.
OK.
Can you see it in this?
It's a little bit
hard to see it.
I think you can see it if
I turn the lights down.
This is the quadratic
regulator again.
Now this isn't quite
the quadratic regulator
from the double integrator.
This is now a quadratic
cost function on a nonlinear
dynamical system, OK.
In this case, the
dynamics are smooth.
They're non-linear,
but they're smooth.
There's nothing that changes
abruptly in the derivatives.
And the cost function
is smooth, but you
can find that the optimal
policy can actually still
be discontinuous, OK.
So costs-- so why
is it discontinuous?
In this case, because if I'm
here and I'm going this way,
I want to push up, but at some
point, I have to change my mind
and go the opposite way to pump
up energy and get to the top.
So this pump up strategy is
inherently discontinuous, OK.
So this is the Gordian
knot of optimal control,
is as soon as things
stop being linear,
computing optimal cost to go
functions can get arbitrarily
hard, OK.
And that's why computation's
so great, because it
does that stuff for me.
But know that it doesn't
take much to make it
so the cost to go function
gets a lot more subtle.
Mm-hmm.
Good.
So the class will proceed taking
these methods as far as we can,
breaking them, and
then showing you
approximation methods that work
in higher dimensional spaces.
And when we give up on
optimality all together,
we'll do motion
planning, and we're
going to get to more and
more interesting robots.
But this is really a key idea.
So I hope that the
intuition came through and--
through your problems set.
And I can share some of
this code and everything.
I hope you play with
it, and think about it,
and change cost functions,
and see what happens.
OK, see you next week.